en pleine nature sept artistes
finalistes sa sculpture dans le parc de
l'hôtel de ville d'andrésy originaire de
côte d'ivoire ce peintre sculpteur est
en pleine réalisation du fed' yenni
l'oiseau protecteur il fait partie des
13 artistes présents pour la 23e édition
de sculptures en l'île parce qu'elle
protège
la population ces symboles de ma de
maturité de fertilité et de fraternité
je l'avais prévu elle a représenté ici
mais elle a coïncidé avec un peu avec la
réalité qui se passe en ce moment avec
ces histoires de racisme aux états unis
ici avec la faire à la main en france
tout ça pour que j'ai jugé bon de nous
représenter un peu évoqué peut-être
réunir et un peu tout le monde
cette oeuvre est réalisé avec le bois de
la scène car pour cet artiste il est
important de s'acclimater à l'endroit où
ils se trouvent et utilise seulement
davis un peu plus loin cet artiste lui
utilise du gaffeur pour son oeuvre est
l'araignée de la maison du moussel
l'oeuvre c'est une anamorphose donc
l'anamorphose c'est une déformation
optique et si vous voulez lorsqu'on se
retrouve confronté à une anamorphose on
se retrouve confronté à un espace à des
volumes à du relief
on a d'un côté un bâtiment qui est
remarquable par son architecture c'est
un bâtiment de style louis 15 édifié par
un architecte à la fin du 19e et puis de
l'autre côté on a une oeuvre de la
nature une pure oeuvre de la nature la
toile d'araignée pour voir les soixante
oeuvres de l'exposition d'art
contemporain le circuit de visite sera
modifié à andrésy en raison de la crise
sanitaire les artistes vont exposer
leurs oeuvres sur le centre ville
d'andrésy comme chaque année simplement
il n'y aura pas les expositions dans
l'île elle-même puisque dans l'île
elle-même comme vous le savez nous avons
dû limiter le nombre de visiteurs dans
l'île le nombre de visiteurs qui passent
en bateau et que donc pour cette année
la manifestation se fera uniquement sur
le centre-ville du parc de la maison des
mots sel jusqu'à la place du mais la
manifestation a été décalée elle débute
le 2 juillet et sera prolongé jusqu'au
1er novembre l'exposition sculptures en
l'île a accueilli l'année dernière plus
de 50000 visiteurs